[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain an american action
thriller film called
run hide fight spoilers ahead watch out
and take care
zoe hall is a senior in high school
after the recent death of her cancerous
mother zoe has completely pulled out of
life one morning she and her father todd
are on a hunting mission he aims at a
buck that doesn't die instantly after
getting shot the father and daughter
have two options either wait and let the
animal die a painful death or mercy kill
it as todd tries explaining what might
be a better option zoe picks up a rock
and slams it into the buck's head todd
is left shocked at the lack of sympathy
she feels for the animal he knows her
strange behavior is rooted in the trauma
caused by her mother's death later
during breakfast zoe hallucinates
talking to her mother as she frequently
does she knows it sounds crazy and
hasn't told anyone yet but talking to
her is the only thing that gives zoe
comfort in life her best friend lewis
comes to pick her up for school on their
way they're troubled by a vehicle full
of douchebags from their school who send
their car off the road while waiting for
it to start zoe notices one of her
classmates named chris placing an object
in the middle of the field she thinks it
is weird but it is normal for someone
like chris who is considered an outcast
today is the senior prank day at school
the senior students place several silly
tricks on teachers which both zoe and
lewis dread in class zoe's chemistry
teacher mrs jane notices her obvious
change in behavior after her mother's
unfortunate death she tries talking to
her about it but is instantly dismissed
following that zoe finds a promposal
from lewis inside her locker she never
wanted to go to the prom and is dreading
that she will have to reject him they
meet in the cafeteria at lunch but she
tries avoiding the subject lewis brings
it up and clarifies that he is asking
her as a friend because he doesn't want
them to be home when the rest of the
school is having fun zoe is clearly
upset and excuses herself to go to the
bathroom at the same time several
unharmful explosions are taking place
throughout the city the police
paramedics and firemen are busy trying
to control the situation it is clear
that the explosions are intentional when
zoe walks into the bathroom she sees a
bully anna hiding something above a vent
after the bully leaves she checks the
vent but finds nothing back in the
cafeteria a van suddenly drives in
through the glass door and hits a guy
the guy zoe had seen earlier that
morning named chris steps out of the
vehicle and shoots the injured man dead
he is joined by a group of three anna
from the bathroom earlier who is also
chris's sister the school's loser kip
and the leader of the gang tristan they
are the ones who planted explosives all
around the town just to distract the
police and are here to shoot up the
place they kill a few people right away
to assert their dominance and force the
others to keep quiet zoe is about to
walk out of the bathroom when one of the
injured girls barges in and begs for
help zoe panics but can do nothing for
her before she passes away she realizes
something is extremely wrong and
carefully steps out to listen to the
shooter's conversation the leader
tristan tells the students that they are
now hostages who will have to obey all
of his orders he spots a guy in the
crowd who used to bully him in the
hallways every day chris shoots the guy
dead without the leader's permission
although tristan wanted to do the same
he tells chris to be calm and only use
the gun when permitted kip walks to the
bathroom to check if everyone is out zoe
senses this and quickly climbs up the
vent before getting caught she then
crawls through it hoping to reach the
other exit meanwhile tristan asks a girl
to pull her phone out and call someone
she loves she calls her mother explains
the situation and tells her mother that
she loves her the mother on the other
end promises to call the police
immediately after the call tristan tells
everyone the police have been informed
so they can skip trying to secretly call
them now he even allows them to call
their parents one last time before their
deaths the group does is told and sends
a tearful goodbye to their loved ones in
case they don't return home today when
zoe is over the kitchen the vent breaks
and she falls to the floor the noise
invites chris in who looks for the
intruder the kitchen lady comes outside
to save a hiding zoe and takes a bullet
for her zoe is left shocked at her limp
self lying on the floor but she composes
herself quickly dresden then calls the
school's receptionist and tells her
about the dead students she doesn't
believe him but informs the security
guard and the principal immediately
somewhere else zoe manages to step out
of the school through the back door in
the kitchen she meets a group of
classmates and informs them of what is
happening inside following the call
tristan asks all hostages to start a
live stream on any platform they wish to
he wants to make a statement and let the
entire world know what he is doing the
stream starts and he asks all the
platforms to cooperate because if they
ban the streams more people will die as
he introduces himself to the world the
principal barges in with the security
guard instead of being scared tristan
welcomes the man and inquires if they
know why he is doing all of this the
principle reveals that tristan was
called to his office twice last week
because of his failing grades and bad
behavior the principal called him a
worthless man who will never amount to
anything but the shootout is not about
just a few meetings for tristan he is a
well-spoken and well-educated man who
has been beaten and bullied by society
the principal tries calming him down but
is shot dead in the process the security
guard on the other hand is allowed to
escape lewis turns out to have the most
live viewers among the hostages hence
tristan makes him the primary cameraman
and brings him to the front meanwhile
zoe goes to every individual classroom
to alert them of the situation while
some teachers chase her away thinking it
is just a prank others believe her still
it will take a lot of time to inform
them one by one zoe rings the fire alarm
so everyone would get out on their own
however anna who is in the electrical
room kills a guard and destroys all the
switches this turns the alarm off and
everyone who had come out of their
classroom goes back inside the
receptionist announces from the speakers
that the school is in lockdown and asks
the students to stay put just then the
first batch of policemen arrive by now
some channels have started to pick up
the news but tristan wants them to
broadcast the live stream on national
television when zoe finally reaches the
receptionist's desk a bag of explosives
goes off killing everyone but her the
group had already planned the attack so
the students won't be notified but the
explosion was a bit late zoe
hallucinates her mother talking to her
telling her that the situation is absurd
suddenly anna comes into her view so she
pretends to be dead after she walks away
zoe bangs on a classroom door to
continue alerting people however anna
hears her and comes looking for the
noise zoe tries to escape but her leg is
shot in the process the girls end up in
the teacher's room which is filled with
balloons that the students arranged as a
prank zoe hides inside the room and
attacks when anna is vulnerable after a
little bit of a struggle she manages to
shoot her dad the police find out about
tristan's family background and address
a policeman goes to his home only to
find his mother lying dead on the sofa
she seems to have been there for a few
days now it is evident that tristan
killed her meanwhile in school tristan
puts chris in charge and makes his way
to his spanish class the teacher asks
him to stop but he in turn makes her
take her top off she has to reluctantly
stand in front of the camera as the
thousands of people in the live stream
watch her then todd hears the news about
the shooting and rushes to the school in
his truck by now several parents police
and reports have gathered outside chris
starts hearing voices in his head which
is the main reason why he joined tristan
in the mission the voices make him fire
at the police outside the noise attracts
tristan's attention and he returns to
the cafeteria taking the spanish teacher
and her students with him moments later
kip bumps into zoe and follows her while
firing at her they end up in a slippery
hallway where zoe attacks him with a
fire extinguisher and knocks him out she
then brings him to the auditorium and
handcuffs him to a seat her mother
appears yet again and talks about how
zoe is holding her back from being fully
dead because she cannot let go of her
when kip wakes up he sees her talking to
herself and instantly assumes she is
like him zoe inquires why he got
involved in the shooting it turns out
that he was stripped naked in front of
the assembly in middle school ever since
people have giggled behind his back zoe
asks if he ever thought that the people
giggling were just happy she belittles
him for killing those who didn't have
anything to do with the bullying she
also mentions that more people are going
to talk about the assembly incident when
they find out he is involved in the
shooting the comment seems to trigger
his trauma and makes him wake up from
all the propaganda tristan has fed him
zoe comes outside to retrieve kip's gun
and finds mrs jane escorting her class
outside the teacher sees the gun and
assumes zoe is also a shooter but she is
quick to explain otherwise she helps
them out but refuses to go out herself
until she helps the other students mrs
jane also joins her before they make
their way to the library a rescued
student tells todd that his daughter
helped them and stayed in the school to
help the others the news is bittersweet
for a father tristan quickly catches on
that someone is helping the students
escape he calls anna's number and
demands to talk to the person behind all
of this zoe bravely tells him that she
killed anna tristan asks her to come to
the cafeteria in five minutes before he
starts murdering the hostages to let her
know that he is being serious he shoots
a random girl todd watches this on the
live stream and brings his hunting rifle
out deciding to save his daughter on his
own inside zoe goes to kip who is now
drowning in regret this makes it easier
for her to convince him to change sides
she puts all of her trust in him and
hands him the gun before making her way
to the cafeteria tristan is surprised to
see that zoe is the one causing trouble
for him as he remembers seeing her in
the hallways a few times she confidently
stands in front and challenges him just
then kip arrives in the back to protect
her tristan laughs knowing that kip was
not good enough to be involved in the
first place a shootout ensues in which
chris kills kip zoe and lewis take the
opportunity to run away while being
followed by chris after running for a
while lewis reveals that he was shot zoe
takes him to an office and lays him down
on the sofa before kissing him she
promises to go to prom together and runs
outside trying to divert chris towards
her they end up in the chemistry lab
where zoe turns the gas on and gives
rise to a minor explosion the flames are
enough to catch todd's attention who is
now in the woods behind the school he
has snuck in to save his daughter
eventually chris finds zoe and is about
to kill her but seconds before todd
shoots him dead the police find him
right after and arrest him but he is
relieved to have saved his daughter
tristan calls chris on the phone but zoe
picks up by her side is her mother who
encourages her to fight harder zoe sends
tristan a picture of chris's dead body
and asks him what he thinks of it
tristan sees his entire plan failing now
that he is alone as a last resort he
enters the van and triggers an explosive
on the call zoe tells him that all of
his work was a waste he wanted to prove
a point to people but instead of him the
public will remember her tristan
realizes it is true and loses his mind
he chooses a random guy from the
hostages and takes him to the rooftop
leaving the others alone zoe returns to
the cafeteria where she sees the
explosive only has 40 seconds to go off
she makes the hostages run away and
quickly gets the van outside fortunately
the explosion that follows doesn't hurt
anyone she then returns to the hallways
where a swat officer holds her down at
that moment zoe's mother wishes her
farewell and goes away having finally
been freed from zoe's heart in the
following scene the sheriff meets zoe
and shakes her hand praising her bravery
he informs her that tristan was burned
to a crisp in an explosion after a brief
chat she goes to meet her father who has
been arrested in a police car he tells
her how proud he is lewis is also being
escorted into an ambulance and is out of
a critical state but then zoe notices
someone suspicious walking out of the
school she retrieves her father's rifle
and follows the man the person digs up
some money from the side of a creek zoe
aims the rifle at him realizing that it
is tristan who probably faked his death
to get away she shoots him in the chest
before approaching him he hasn't died
yet just like the buck at the beginning
of the film but unlike the buck he
doesn't deserve her mercy so she leaves
him to die a painful death in the last
scene we see her returning to the school
grounds and informing the sheriff of
what happened subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching